good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday it's a
beautiful tuesday here in
wherever you are hey claude how you
doing hello jacqueline happy tuesday i
hope everyone's having a great day
i am
feeling good you're feeling good
yeah well it's january 25th which is a
really special day for me
because it's the one year anniversary of
your book correct well 50 right yes
today is the one year anniversary of the
day my book came out last year which is
just always going to be a happy time in
my life because i loved writing my book
i made the new york times bestsellers
list everyone seemed to really like it
and then the january 25th before that
was the day i sold out and performed at
the beacon theater so it's just like a
really special day for me and then
what's on deck for today how do you beat
those two things
well today is the release of my book in
paperback the one year anniversary this
is the paperback version i'm holding in
my hand
ooh
it still has the picture inserts
and if you're watching on youtube you
see i have the new york times bestseller
little stamp on the book which is what
i'm particularly really excited about
this is a great size if you're traveling
it's very flexible you could beat it up
um it's available now everywhere you get
your books paperback queen over here
that's very exciting i'm glad you're
three for three on january 25th glad
this day could be extra special what do
you think is going to happen next 25th
oh
anything could happen so much could
happen between now and then no
like you could give first
you could give birth next january 25th
girl
calm down you could come down
technically
no no i could yes
will i
think about it
something to think about because you're
gonna you're gonna have to top yourself
could get another dog you know i know um
yeah i'll figure something out for next
january 25th but um i'm just happy with
this year's 25th okay and then you have
your book event tonight
yes so i'm just like busy busy busy
today so i'm so glad we're getting this
podcast out a little earlier than we
usually do because i know you're busy
i'm busy we're just like all busy
meetings meetings meetings except for me
it's doctors appointments doctors
appointments doctors appointments i have
all of them today so um we have to get
this show on the road so that i can go
see some pics of elsa i'm excited
yeah i'm excited for photos of lc update
on lc's journey and do you ever think
like at this stage when you go to the
doctor like maybe they'll just induce
you
no it's too early for that i think but i
mean you never know what could happen
hopefully i'll get some more information
on like what i can expect when i can
expect but i also don't even think i'll
get that i think they'll just send me
home and tell me to
you know come back in two weeks or
whatever
keep sitting down
yeah so we'll see what happens but i
just i love getting the information like
to see a checkup like to know how much
baby's weighing etc so
looking forward to hearing all of that
that's very exciting yeah
so other than that how was your day
yesterday anything new and exciting for
you have you done your wordle yet
i did wordle was yesterday the first day
i couldn't do did you get it i got it on
the fifth try it was a hard one though
the hard k in the double l
it's not a spoiler now because it's a
new day i haven't done today's yet but
it's um something i've really come to
look forward to
yeah no it's it's a really good brain
exercise for all of us who are just like
frying our brains on our phone all day
i'm really glad that everyone's also
taking up wordle to get you know uh 10
minutes of brain exercise
and i feel like it's definitely helping
a little bit
it can't hurt
but there should be more than one like
you should be able to do a bunch if you
want it's a little annoying well i told
you about i told you about the world
archive right
yeah you sent that to me i was playing
with that for a while
that's like a good practice but yes but
i think the thing that's going to keep
people excited about it for longer than
the usual internet attention span is the
fact that you can only do one a day so
we're still all really excited because
in actuality i've only done like eight
wordles
yeah i guess that's true slow and steady
but it's it's been fun i was like hq
hq
yeah but like everyone was really jazzed
about it at the time because it was like
this thing we were all doing once a day
but i think they eventually moved to
twice a day
yeah yeah oh wow what did that was like
so long ago now that's like more than
five years ago
because that was like breathtaking
the toast for five years yes
but does anyone know anyone who ever won
hq
i don't i don't
me neither
let us know if you do drop your story
spooky
drop the story
i think we should get into the fastback
we have a lot to talk about today we
have a lot of stories we have dear
toasters i need to know what you guys
are up to do we have any updates
oh i haven't checked yet because you
know i like to read blind so let me
check right now but also
um we have a lot to do today but we also
have to tell you guys that we recorded
a really great um
okay there's no oh there's an update oh
my god and i don't know what i'm looking
at but there's also a picture
exciting visual scenes an email update
with a picture so i'm not going to read
it because i want to be surprised um
but yes yesterday we recorded a really
great patreon we told you guys a couple
like a week ago that we did toe secret
and there was just such an overwhelming
response from that episode that we did a
part two because so many more people
submitted their deepest darkest secrets
and this one got
pretty crazy there were a lot of secrets
i feel like the first episode really
inspired the second batch to come with
their biggest and their baddest secrets
and you guys are wild you're wild um
there's just so much to unpack so head
over to patreon.com after this episode
and indulge in there's now two episodes
of secrets so if you are harboring a
secret like that you can feel better
about it knowing that there's at least
one in there that's [ __ ] crazier than
yours that's worse
yeah that i think was the whole
kind of therapy behind this episode one
obviously the concept of unburdening
yourself with your secret giving it to
us that feels good but then hearing
other people's secrets knowing like the
thing that keeps you up at night it's
not even close to as bad as a thing
that's keeping someone else up at night
it's great it's just like they say the
truth shall set you free
and free it was so head over to
patreon.com the morning toast
okay so now without further ado
how's due quickly i miss i miss him my
sweet love
he's
perfect he's special he's unique he's
charismatic and he's one of a kind
really how's brew
oh incredible angel boy loves his mommy
so much hi brew how are you he's
watching from the love sack
he's not the best seat in the house he
really does if only i put heating pad on
the love sack he would be in brew heaven
but he looks pretty cozy right now
okay without further ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
the pill club go to the pharmacy in
person is so 2021 get your birth control
online prescribed and delivered for free
with the pill club never make a trip to
the doctor for your prescription or wait
in line at the pharmacy ever again the
pill club provides personalized care
from the comfort of your home and
delivery to your door on time every time
so the pill club offers birth control
subscriptions prescribed by medical
professionals and delivered straight to
your door for free the pill club carries
over 120 fda approved brands and they
ship to all 50 states most brands of
birth control are free with insurance or
medicaid otherwise the prices start as
low as seven dollars a month the pill
club delivers birth control to your door
for free and discreet packaging along
with fun self-care gifts and goodies and
right now when you go to the
pillclub.com toast the pill club is
offering a 10 donation to bedsider.org
for every morning toast listener who
becomes a patient so your donation will
help low-income individuals get access
to birth control through bedsider.org so
you only can get that donation when you
go to the pillclub.com
toast get your first birth control care
package and donate to help more women in
need of affordable birth control
remember that's thepillclub.comtoast
you must use that link to make sure the
donation to bedsider.org goes through
today's episode is also brought to you
by noom
unlike other restrictive diets or
workout programs new weight uses
psychology to empower you with the
practical knowledge and skills you need
to build smarter more sustainable
long-term habits and behaviors
noom doesn't believe in restricting what
you can or can't eat instead noom gives
you the knowledge and wisdom you need to
make informed choices that not only fit
your lifestyle but also help you reach
your goals an off day is totally okay
and it will not set you off course new
weight gently helps you back on track
and you're the boss you decide how nume
weight fits into your life not the other
way around 5 10 or 15 minutes a day
however time you want to spend on the
app is up to you and there's a lot of
really good science behind you more than
75 percent of users have completed the
program i know before you're pregnant
jackie you were really into new
especially their food tracker and their
food database
yeah it's a great way to stay on track
whatever your goals are whether they're
lofty or they're just about maintenance
and you know holding yourself
accountable every day and knowing what's
going into your body noom is the perfect
resource to track all of that and
learn more about what you're eating and
what's in it and what you could be doing
differently or better that you don't
even realize so i'm a big fan of noom
check it out
sign up for your trial and get
psychology-based support and motivation
to reach your goals at noom.com n-o-o-m
dot com slash toast that's n o o m
dot com slash toast to sign up for your
trial
n-o-o-m
stop
i just wanna make sure people can hear
me
because the words the letters sound
similar trying to help people change
their lives they won't forget now
and
okay you guys our first story of the day
is the most important news of the day
that i was rdh that i did not bring up
yesterday everyone is tagging me in this
mason ramsey has gone viral again we
have an update from lil hank williams
himself cause mason has been quite m.i.a
for the last year or so especially you
know after his
rise to stardom as you know him as the
walmart yodel boy he put out his ep he
was everywhere touring here there and i
really feel like once covet started like
mason really became pretty low-key
a number of things have happened in the
last few weeks that have thrust mason
back into the spotlight
first his song one of his songs from his
ep is going viral on tick tock do you
want to tell us about the trend
yeah so it's a song called before i knew
it it's really cute and it's just like a
very short little country dance that
people were doing and then when they put
the pieces together that it was a mason
ramsay song it led the internet down
this second mason ramsay rabbit hole
only to find out not only is mason
ramsey doing very well he's home he
works at subway he's returned to a very
normal life of a 15 year old he's
extremely humble he's taking a break
from you know singing he's 15 now so
he's going through
puberty he's going through an
interesting time and he has reverted
back to normal life he works at subway
when people on tick tock found that out
they were quaking because he went from
walmart to subway he said he he's been
answering questions now he says he's
been working there for over a year he's
never been happier he's just feeling
really good he's gonna come back but he
just needed some time off and i don't
know i just i i too am obsessed beyond
belief with this story
yeah it's really it's so beautiful on a
number of levels one to see mason like
thriving doing well you love to see it
two a lot of times when people like
shoot to stardom their families like
don't know how to handle it they like
try and ride the wave for as long as
possible they exploit the kids it's
really like sad and it doesn't really
end well because every what goes up must
come down all good things must come to
an end and you're not going to have that
viral
excitement forever so the fact that he's
like resumed normal life he's working at
subway he's a hard-working guy i i'm so
like
impressed by him and like his
grandparents that they have just
continued to live as an as normal life
as possible and i think mason and he's
so talented so he has a career waiting
for him when he's older whether he wants
it or not but he should spend these next
few years like trying to be a normal
person and not be stunted at the age
that he became famous which was 12 and i
just feel like these grandparents need
to write a book on child stars because
they're doing everything right
i completely agree like i've never
gotten a you know a follow-up piece of
information about mason ramsay that put
a pit in my stomach or that made me
think like is he doing the right thing
and you know i think we said this when
he was in the midst of going viral the
first time it seems like he has really
good support behind him like of course
his grandparents you know they've lived
a very simple life up until this point
they didn't know how to handle this and
every you know talent agent and everyone
wanted to work with mason back in the
day and i feel like he made really good
decisions about who to surround himself
with they never overworked him they
never made him like you know
over exploited and now they've given him
the space to kind of retreat back to his
normal life but you know the this
society
still wants him like he's so
desirable so i love that for him and i
agree he will be able to whether or not
he wants one is still up for debate but
when he grows up officially he can make
the decision if he wants to go into
music or if he wants to have a normal
life and i think that that's so rare and
you have to attribute that to really
good grandparenting
yeah and he has all the music contacts
now he knows the people in the biz he's
worked with like so many of the biggest
artists so even if the dream ends there
for him like his dreams came true
and if not he has a like a runway open
and available to himself so i just felt
like this was such a beautiful
unexpected update i didn't even realize
how quiet he had been not even like not
putting out music or doing the shows but
also just not even on social media like
a kid his age should be tick-tocking
especially like if he's a thirsty former
viral star like i don't want to compare
you know thirsty formal viral child
stars but there are some who you know
thirst out all the way until we're
really [ __ ] sick of them so this is a
beautiful update thank you everyone i
mean it's so funny what
people send like what you get copious
amounts of dms about like stories or
memes that like make what people do
associate with you
so this mason ramsay story i must have
gotten a hundred dm's about it also
there's this meme that like whenever a
big meme account posts it everybody tags
me and it's like me and every photo and
it's all the different emojis with a
peace eye next to it
have you seen that one like it was just
reposted yeah so um
it's always it's always a delight to see
what makes people think of me and i'm so
glad that it's mason ramsay
no that's really endearing and this was
a great story i
you know you're right like when it comes
to situations like this updates aren't
always going to be positive but you know
at the very least like
even if you know all this goes away i
thought i feel solace knowing that like
mason ramsey still knows who he is
and at at least he can have a successful
career as an influencer because he has
crazy amounts of followers people are
just gravitate towards him and it's like
he doesn't even want it i guess that's a
sign of like a really you know star
they're like i don't even care about it
and like people just can't stop checking
in on him what's mason up to what's
mason
doing no that's true there is this like
desire from everyone to know what he's
up to yeah must be nice
and i would just love to eat a sandwich
made by mason ramsay even though i
literally detest
subway i would eat it for mason he would
have to bring it outside because i'm not
going in there i'll have to do
drive-through
hopefully he's working the drive-through
window
because i'm not going into that smelly
meat locker
but it's also good to know that
that is top five the funniest thing
you've ever said i mean
ramsay bringing you a sandwich to the
parking lot you all know that we talk
once a year about like how the smell of
subway and either like you despise it or
you like revel in it and clearly mason
and i differ on this issue but it's fine
i like i can accept that and as long as
he'll bring my sandwich to the curb we
don't have an issue
oh my god you are too funny
just you know something to think about
well happy for mason and like today's
just a day of talking about our favorite
people because are you ready for our
next story
yes
taylor swift is slamming a singer who
claimed that she doesn't write her own
songs so taylor swift engaged in some
twitter pete beef yesterday with
musician damon albarn for claiming in a
new interview that she doesn't write her
own songs who right um he's uh the front
man for the band blur and he's also in
gorillas with a z
uh yeah no and i'm also in um
the band called
the band called this joke
flying flat yeah i know i couldn't think
of something but like okay
all i'm saying is using nobody so yeah i
didn't know recognize his name i went to
his picture still didn't recognize now
hearing these band names gorilla sounds
familiar but still like unfamiliar yeah
so he did an interview with the la times
said that taylor doesn't write her own
songs she took to twitter to say at
damon albarn i was such a big fan of
yours until i saw this i write all of my
own songs your hot take is completely
false and so damaging you don't have to
like my songs but it's really [ __ ] up
to try and discredit my writing wow then
she wrote p.s i wrote this tweet all by
myself in case you were wondering
then some of taylor's collaborators came
to her side to co confirm that she
indeed writes her own songs such as
aaron desner and nathan chapman and now
damon albarn has apologized
he said i apologize unreservedly and
unconditionally the last thing i would
want to do is discredit your songwriting
i hope you understand
well he also had initially said that you
know um he hates that the magazine you
know took something he said out of
context and used it for clickbait which
is such like a
cop-out cause like that might be
possible that they did that but like you
still said it
yeah
so i went to the
quote where he said it he was talking
about like billy eilish and he was
comparing like taylor and billy and that
like billy writes her own songs in more
of a way than taylor does because taylor
co-writes her songs i didn't even know
that this was a thing i just who doesn't
associate taylor swift with writing her
own songs
it's so dumb like to take have such a
hot take that's just like factually
inaccurate like and the thing is and
there's a lot of things that bothered me
about this and like you know say what
you want about taylor like some people
have problems with her whatever the one
thing you actually cannot say about her
is that she doesn't write her own music
that's like literally her thing and i
get why it bothered her so much and i
think some some like a devil's advocate
would be like well why does she care
what this random man said like he's a
nobody but it's like the one thing no
one's ever really been able to take away
from her and that would bother me too
especially on a platform like the la
times and i'm assuming she knows who
this man is because i don't
yeah of course i would never have seen
this story if she didn't talk about it i
would never know who this man was if she
didn't talk about it so she's also like
giving air and more you know of a
platform to these accusations i just i
don't understand why he would even say
that when
she's like wrong she either does or she
doesn't and she does so why would she
say he say that she doesn't
there was also another thing that
bothered me about this okay so i'm going
to read you like the context in which
the conversation was being had
so
he had said something and the
interviewer was like so you think a lot
of modern musicians are relying on sound
and attitude
and he goes name me someone who's not
and then the art the journalist goes she
may not be to your taste but taylor
swift is an excellent songwriter he goes
she doesn't write her own songs they go
of course she does blah blah and i just
don't understand why like you have to
preface that question like that
follow-up she may not be your taste
why is your taste not good
okay you don't like good music
would you have said you know she may not
be your taste
but
dolly parton you wouldn't say that like
you would just say dolly parton you know
um i guess but you would also say it
about other people not it's not just
like something
about taylor
so that's i i do believe that it is it
feels like you know if you're gonna
bring up taylor's accolades you always
have to preface it like well you know
you might not love her but you have to
respect her well why can't you just love
her literally everyone does there's a
reason she's literally the biggest pop
star on the planet
yeah
yeah i guess so
interesting because he's just such
losery vibes like
and justice for this man's social media
because the swifties have descended upon
it um as they should
and i just think this man i didn't know
this man before i don't want to know
this man now and what i do know about
this man is like he's obviously a loser
who just says stuff like he's just like
such an artist he has to like downplay
popular music and if you're gonna do
that like at least get your facts
straight [ __ ] like you're wrong
yeah
yeah or come with some receipts or
something because
that's like
taylor swift is a songwriter of our
generation so if you want to say that
she's not then just let us know how so
you know
yeah and his whole his com his
you know
thing he said about co-writing which i
do understand like i think we talk about
that sometimes on the toast like
you can be a singer who really does not
write her own songs but you're always
listed as a co-writer because if you're
in the room or you're on the phone with
you know you get a list a writing credit
and that's like a thing and i get the
the
the argument he's trying to make there
but like taylor swift is not the face of
co-writing like not at all
yeah i didn't even know that co-writing
is such a slanderous accusation um and
it's really just like if you were in the
room or maybe you told the songwriters
your story and they put it to lyrics but
yeah if you just want to like blow up
like the biggest thing that
taylor like her claim to fame really
then you're gonna then like saying it
and then taking it right back like you
look like a big loser
the big no not only saying it and then
blaming it on like journalists click
bait and then apologizing like
i'm all for blaming journalists don't
get me wrong but you did have to say it
for it to be in the article right so
either you miss like you really misspoke
and that's kind of just like a weird
thing to
get wrong or like back it up be like no
she co-writes my friend said this blah
blah blah
yeah
no i don't think he ever expected like
her to
literally tweet when i saw like taylor
swift tweeted something i'm like oh my
god a new song what's going on
and i'm like oh we're yelling at another
man i'm like okay um and uh my first
question was who is this man
yeah me too and i still didn't get an
answer really
i'm still still unsure of any of his
music
unfamiliar with his work but wishing him
the best of luck in the future
yeah
anyways glad that we cleared that up
though
that she cleared that up yeah
okay and like
any more thoughts
no no i'm done with my thoughts now i'm
done okay okay let us know if anything
comes up just let it all out
our next story what
what did you say
what'd you say i said the next story is
brought to you by stamps.com if you're a
small business owner you're busy enough
as it is you don't have time to deal
with the hassle of going to the post
office with stamps.com you can skip the
trip and never waste another dollar or
minute stamps.com lets you print
official postage right from your
computer so you can spend less time at
the post office and more time running
your business
stamps.com saves you time money and
stress for more than 20 years they have
been an indispensable asset for over 1
million businesses stamps.com gives you
access to all the post office and ups
shipping services that you need right
from your computer and you'll get
discounts you can't find anywhere else
like up to 40 percent off usps and 67.76
off ups whether you're an office sending
out invoices a side hustle etsy shop or
a full-blown warehouse shipping out
orders stamps.com will make your life a
little easier
all you need is a computer and a printer
no special supplies or equipment needed
save time and money this year with
stamps.com sign up with promo code toast
for a special offer that includes a
four-week trial free postage and a
digital scale there's no long term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the page and enter code toast
great is that what you were trying to
say
before no oh okay no you you weren't
hearing me and i was just like you know
what [ __ ] this i'm going into an ad
break
i need a break
okay literally
next story adele's show postponement
story is just crumbling around her
sources are saying that it was postponed
over disputes not covid tmz says that uh
their sources say adele was unhappy with
various set pieces acquire the sound
system and other items associated with
the show several sources said they could
not satisfy her production demands they
say she felt numerous elements were not
good enough and then also page six is
reporting that she postponed the
residency after
a rant over a swimming pool stunt i
guess she wanted to stand in the middle
of a swimming pool during her
performance but she compared the final
design to an old pond and refused to do
so when she saw the final design she
refused to take part
yeah i'm not to be like you know i knew
it but i really didn't think it was
covet and i don't think most of us did
yeah i just live in a day and age where
like you can ever have this one excuse
me yeah it's amazing
yeah until like someone calls you out on
it and now it's like not only did you
disappoint the fans and this and that
but you've also lied and i just still i
can't fathom how abysmal it could have
been also vegas has like every single
production
element available to them and
it just seems like there were so many
like i'm reading different stuff from
like the set designer and like sources
and whatnot it seems like there's just
like so much friction on set and it's
like either one how does this not happen
more often when there's just so many
personalities or two like
what the [ __ ] it feels like something's
very off
or maybe she was really trying to do
something that couldn't be done like she
was going so outrageous but which is
just so not adele because as we said in
depth last week like
her
show is her voice and there could be you
know a choir and an orchestra and she
can make it beautiful but she doesn't
need a swimming pool like
at all
no she does not need a swimming pool uh
also have you seen that she's been like
face timing fans and like dm'ing them
like fans who were supposed to be at the
show and like
trying to make it right yeah no it it's
really nice but it's like it's desperate
it's giving like oh it's giving oh we
don't have coved it's giving like it's
giving guilt
yeah no it's not premium it's not coming
off premium and then she's not adele
she's sending them to like her shop
which is a merge store like sasha
experience
where they can like
look at memorabilia and stuff and
experience adele oh i didn't get to see
adele live but i'm so glad i got to go
to this souvenir shop
yeah said no but it's not just about
buying stuff like first the criticism
was like she's sending her fans to go
spend more money on merch but apparently
there's other things to do there that
it's more like a experiential thing but
still just
no
i feel like this story's dragging again
this is for so long
it's a flop from adele
and so will
is it going to be up this weekend
no i don't think so
yeah because it's weekends with adele so
like oh did she just cancel that one
weekend
oh i didn't even think of that i thought
that's like the whole thing was off it's
postponed
it shouldn't be off
of course not but i i don't know i
didn't think of when it would actually
be returning and now it has to be like
insane barnum bailey's like so that you
can say like this is what we were trying
to do that we couldn't do
it was worth the wait yeah
yeah hmm
it's a very fishy story wishes to adele
it is like just shit's not adding up
yeah
yeah
because otherwise these things would
happen more often if like people do the
craziest [ __ ] concerts and they take
them on the road and they put them in
trucks and they pack like it's crazy
and here you are like you have a theater
circus
right they bring elephants through the
midtown tunnel and you couldn't get the
swimming pool right of your heart's
desire in las vegas the entertainment
capital of the world some would say
me i would say color me skeptical yeah i
would say that too yeah
okay
no points are valid points are being
made i agree
are you ready for our next story
yes
tiffany haddich haddish has is
addressing her dui arrest she's saying
we're going to work it out she joined
the tonight show on monday talking to
jimmy fallon about the situation and at
first she um
joked about it a little bit she talked
about you know breakup with common she
can say she said i can say this jimmy
i've been praying to god to send me a
new man a good man and god went ahead
and sent me four in uniform
then she said um
she said she's dealing with the really
funny she said she's dealing with the
ramifications of the dui she said now i
got a really great lawyer and we're
going to work it out i've got to get my
asking of things to god a little better
um and she was more you know contrite
and serious in talking about how she is
working it out
okay like obviously i want the best for
her i'm always gonna support you know
people bettering themselves but i'm
still living in the disappointment i
really am yeah i think that's fair and
and everything takes time but at least
she's you know confronting it and not
hiding from it and just saying like i'm
[ __ ] up
and i'm i'm working on it
yeah well from a pr perspective sitting
down and doing an interview and just
like talking about like you know
not making it awkward is always the best
thing to do so that i think was like a
good pr move um
but just on a personal level like i'm
still i'm still wallowing in some of my
disappointment because i love tiffany
haddish and i just want to see her
succeed
yeah i think that's that's all fair to
say but you know just knowing that she
um how she feels about it that she's
taking responsibility and trying to also
better herself
is all you can hope for someone to take
out of this as a lesson
agreed agreed it's nice to see her
handling it in a way that i like to
think i would handle it as well
yes
now are you ready for our fifth and
final story
yeah
uh kim kardashian skims and team usa
drop a new collection ahead of the
beijing olympics so kim got that team
usa contract once again for the beijing
games skimz's new capsule capsule
collection marks team usa's ongoing
partnership with her shapewear company
which became the official undergarment
outfitter for team usa during the summer
2021 tokyo olympics and they must have
been just so pleased with her work
because they called her again for the
winter olympics the new capsule
collection is a mix of loungewear
athletic apparel and sleepwear each
piece color blocked in red white and
blue and bearing official team usa and
olympics imagery
this is awesome once again
yeah it is i bought from the first
collection and it's one of my most
prized possessions
um and i was really hoping that like
something similar to what i got in the
first collection which was just like the
jersey long sleeve pajamas was gonna be
in the second collection and there's
just pajama pants there's not a shirt so
i'm like a little annoyed but i love for
k
so happy for kim getting this contract
it reminds me you know the olympics are
like 11 days away i know we haven't even
talked about them
and it's the winter olympics which get
like way less
like juice but they're still really good
yeah
i
oh maybe once they're on i'll start to
feel you know an attachment towards them
but i really i haven't gotten like
revved up yet at all i mean ice skating
is always fun to watch and like the
skiing will be
cool to see but i don't know this
olympics seems like extra
paired down whereas also it's in beijing
we just
had olympics so it's like we're not used
to this
no and the olympics this time around was
way more overwhelming than i had
anticipated of course i was like very
vocally excited about it and then once
it got here i felt extremely overwhelmed
so i'm like definitely in like my break
mode from the olympics and now they're
just coming back because of kovid and
it's it's overwhelming again yeah to say
the least but you want to support the
athletes like these people have trained
their whole lives imagine how like they
feel they're like oh my gosh we're six
months after the summer olympics like
it's just it was a cluster [ __ ] for
everyone so true
when they do premiere like i i will give
it my all in wanting to be invested
well you know
something we were really kind of on top
of was the metal tracker
from
the summer olympics and you know we were
dangerously close to losing in the gold
category to china
and so i'm just like that's my concern
that this could be the one where we do
lose and especially because they're in
china because like no one's paying
attention and they're they and they're
in china yeah so they have home corn
advantage
and this could be the one that we lose
damn that's not enough i'm just saying
no i wouldn't be surprised because it's
like we're not even paying attention and
then like it's just gonna happen behind
our backs you know yeah
oh that's interesting now now the stakes
are higher
i know so i will be too i was very you
know how you said like things people
associate with you like every time nbc
sports would like post the metal tracker
on their instagram story or in a feed
post people i got like thousands of
people sending it to me so that's what
people used to send to me and that's
gonna happen again and you know what it
was very helpful i was always on top of
the tracker always seeing china sneaking
up on us
wow
okay now it's like now i'm back in it
i'm excited will they premiere when do
the olympics it's like in 11 days 11 who
said 11 days
i did
did you okay
but you just threw did i i know i said
it it's but you've seen it yeah yeah
cause like i
i remember them saying a couple days ago
it was 13 days so i was just doing some
math okay cool that'll be exciting and
we'll recap on the toast
also i don't know if i've ever watched a
winter olympics
once i became a skier so now i'm i've
never watched really skiing before and
cared or like understood but now i'm
more invested in skiing as i enjoy it as
a hobby but it's not like
it's not like a leisure ski it's like
the flips and the jumps right but but
that's
really cool knowing what it takes to
leisurely ski green and it's like back
breaking for some of us like
it definitely heightens the stakes plus
you know now i've seen molly's game and
that just like makes me look at olympic
skiing differently
100 you never know who's going to trip
over a twig
you never know who's going to trip over
a twig and then start running an
insanely high profile poker ring you
just never know
anything anything's possible at the
olympics that's an amazing movie
i actually can't it is molly's game i
can't ski without thinking about it
which is not good
really yeah because of like what happens
to her ski it happens in the first five
seconds so right now no i remember
that's a really niche reference yeah but
it was like a complete like one in a
billion chance that something like that
could happen
like where the twig unclips her ski
so
it just always makes you think about it
watch out for twigs
okay so those are the fast five stories
i feel as though you needed to know them
and now we can launch into deer toasters
i'm so excited to hear what you guys
have cooked up for us
today's really special because deer
toasters is brought to you by smelly
pillow
purple
okay so you guys know
i'll give you the whole spiel but purple
is the brand of my smelly pillow that i
hold really near and dear to my heart so
i just wanted to put that out there
so purple mattresses is what they're
known for they have the gel flex grid
which is also in my pillow which is why
i love it so much so it's a super
stretchy very squishy material that
adapts and flex
around pressure points and doesn't
retain heat which is why i love my
smelly pillow so much so the gel flex
grid is their you know trademark
texture it's amazingly supportive for
your back and legs while cushioning your
shoulders neck and hips no matter how
you sleep so they have full mattresses
of this material it's really lush it's
very different than any mattress i've
ever slept on
because unlike memory foam which
remembers everything the gel flex grid
from purple mattresses bounce back as
you move and shift so you never have
that i'm stuck feeling that you get with
some memory foam mattresses so i've
slept on the purple mattress many times
but my personal favorite is their pillow
i know we're technically doing uh an ad
for the mattress and the mattress is
incredible like you'll really never find
a mattress that's like this that really
doesn't hold you down it bounces you up
it doesn't retain heat so if you're a
sweaty sleeper it just feels so good
knowing like you're not like absorbing
all your disgusting sweat into your
mattress it's just it's a different kind
of sleep
you could try your purple mattress
risk-free with free shipping and returns
and they also have financing available
so getting a great night's sleep starts
with having a great mattress get a
purple mattress go to purple.com tmt and
use the code tmt for a limited time you
can get 10 off any order of 200 or more
so that's purple.com tmt as in the
morning toast and the code is tmt so you
got to use both purple.com tmt code tmt
for the 10 off any order of 200 or more
purple.com tmt promo code tmt terms
apply
all right
dear toasters is our advice segment if
you ever want to write and it's dear
toasters gmail.com we will always keep
it anonymous for you when you could
write in about anything you want and
today we have two submissions and one
update finally also if you loved your
toasters we are doing a patreon episode
all dedicated to deer toasters so
whether if you just like to listen to
the deer toasters head over to
patreon.com morning toast it will be up
later this week or if you want to submit
something but you don't want it on like
the main public show and you want it in
the private one um
email us deartoasters gmail.com and use
subject uh patreon in the subject line
and we will include it so that's really
fun now we're ready
all right first first up dear claudia
jackie bruce and theo i'm sorry i
couldn't think of a better opener for
this email but that's honestly how i've
been feeling for the last several days
ugh i could tell you a long convoluted
story of why i had this phone why i
snooped etc but i'll just skip to what
got me so confused this past week i
found a snapchat exchange between my
boyfriend and his gay male friend the
texts were explicit some of them
my boyfriend talking about our sex life
but also including dick pics from my
boyfriend to this guy the texts were
from a few months ago but definitely
since we've been together i asked my
boyfriend about it and he acted like it
wasn't weird at all explaining that this
other guy was just pestering him to send
the pics he obliged and didn't think to
mention it to me because my boyfriend
says he himself isn't gay or even
bicurious this also opened up the
conversation about how my boyfriend has
downloaded an app to explore threesome
opportunities it's something we've
talked about vaguely but not like making
plans he talked to a couple of girls for
us but then deleted the app a day later
i try to stay open-minded and i'm trying
to be understanding and forgiving but
honestly i'm feeling betrayed i feel
like sending a dick pic to anyone
regardless of gender is still crossing a
boundary am i overreacting same with the
texting the other girls for us how is it
for us if i don't even know the
conversations are happening i honestly
feel like he's trying to make these
behaviors
i honestly feel like he's trying to make
these behaviors seem harmless but i feel
like it's making me question whether i
can trust him what do you think where do
i go from here i must say the first
thing i thought when i opened the
snapchat was what the [ __ ] and the
second thing i thought was i have to
email claudia and jackie i'm so grateful
for you and your help so grateful in
fact that i will definitely send an
update love you all
okay he is making you feel crazy and you
are not crazy him sending him sending
his member to anyone other than you or
his doctor
is a no is a big no and then also agreed
like
that he's conversing with women from a
threesome app for you guys but like you
are 50 of that equation as well
and he's being shady and i don't like it
and not only is it shady behavior but
it's also like now mind games
manipulation and if you like can see
yourself living without this man i would
say please do that
i would highly suggest it i think that
this man is first of all like textbook
gaslighting you and he's also acting
really inappropriately like right on the
cusp of like what's cheating and what's
not like he's it's like acceptable in
his mind because it's an app for the
three of us even though i'm excluding
you from excluding you from the entire
process like he's just like right on the
line it's very manipulative and i
actually really don't like this man at
all and i think
this is just the beginning of his
behavior and he rationalize it
rationalizes it to himself and to you by
being like oh he's gay oh i'm doing it
for us like but down the line it won't
be able to be so easily rationalized
yeah and it'll just make you question
like so much stuff like you will really
think like in later in life like he'll
do this about if this is clearly his
personality he'll just do this about
like random [ __ ] and it'll make you
think you're going crazy
and that's just not
how you want to be living your life he
doesn't sound like you know good people
and i would
i would get away as fast as i could
i agree because this is textbook ass
lighting and
you're not going crazy like you're 100
justified in your feelings and it
doesn't sound like i mean you could
always like you know talk about it try
and work on it get to the root of like
why he feels like he needs to lie this
that but sometimes these things are just
like
you know a part of who a person is and
you can't change that yeah
sorry i agree
um well good luck to you here's our
second one
dear jackie and claudia i'm a big
toaster going way back to the morning
breath i can't wait to see claudia at
her fort lauderdale show here's why i'm
writing in
over the holidays i was back in my
hometown and i attended dinner one night
with my dad his new girlfriend and my
two other sisters after dinner my dad's
girlfriend texted in a group chat with
myself and my two sisters saying she had
a great time and asking what we wanted
for christmas
the next morning
imagine my surprise when i open my phone
at 8am and see a text in that same group
chat this group chat is just my dad's
girlfriend my two sisters and i my dad
is not in this group chat
and the text from my dad's girlfriend
says
eggplant emoji
tongue emoji question mark emoji
ew disgusting probably meant for my dad
also at 8am what the [ __ ] so several
weeks have now passed and of course no
one has since responded in the group
chat my question is what do i do the
next time i see her do i reply in the
chat or do we just never mention it
forever sincerely a traumatized toaster
damn i'm sorry don't be rude don't be
rude also acknowledge it you're an adult
it sounds like and
these things happen and sure it's
uncomfortable nobody wants to think
nobody wants to think about this
but
nobody you know
you got to live and let live it's
unfortunate what you can do the most
generous thing you could do is just to
forget about it
i don't think there needs to be a
conversation you know the most generous
thing you could do
is write something in the chat so that
it goes it gets scrolled up and no one
has to like be the first person to text
back no send like a bunch of pictures
next time you're together take a bunch
of pictures and then put them all in the
channel just like flood it that's good
yeah just try and be like
if as long as this woman like is you
know a kind person she makes your dad
happy like and there's no you know evil
stepmom things happening just there's no
meredith blake give her a pass like that
sucks
it's worse for her than it is for you
just know that okay
yes that's horrifying that's horrifying
i wonder if she told your dad like oh my
god i [ __ ] up with the kids or she's
just like holding this in just i think
we need to give her a little grace
yeah me too like it sounds like she was
nice she asked what you wanted for
christmas like she's trying and she
[ __ ] up and she's probably like
literally going in over and over in her
mind like a thousand times like oh this
is a really important relationship and
like i [ __ ] up with the daughters just
try and be graceful you know older
people aren't as good with text messages
just be nice
yeah and just be happy for your dad that
he's getting his his dick sucked yeah
at his age like you know it's not always
a given no
oh my god
how it's horrible i'm in pain
all right the third one is an update
hello jackie and claudia first off many
congratulations to you both jackie on
becoming a mom and claudia on the end
log tour so i was the toaster whose
boyfriend allowed our chocolate lab to
take over our bed and push him to my
side leaving me a sliver on our queen
bed and or sometimes pushing me off the
bed
i ended up taking both of your advice
not only did i lay down the law with
both of them that i needed more room for
a [ __ ]
good night's sleep but i also kicked my
boyfriend out of the bed one night when
i literally couldn't take it anymore to
which he ended up sleeping on our dog's
bed with the visual attached oh my god
she sent a picture her
husband is dead asleep on the floor it's
hard wood and the chocolate lab is
deliciously cuddled up in his dog bed
so to top it off we have just
so cute to top it off we have just moved
to a place to a place where i've seen
the snow this year and i finally have
enough room for a king bed claudia you
were right it is life-changing thank you
ladies for your advice to a fellow
toaster i hope you have just as much
luck with the advice that these queens
give you exo a well-rested toaster
oh you love a happy ending you love you
love dna
and that's just further proof that a
king bed can really save even the worst
relationship i i mean i look forward to
the upgrade right now we're still in a
queen we will get a king
probably in the next few months
um and i'm just so excited because even
last night like we were having um i
actually had a germ is so big i know and
it's so funny when i like post instagram
stories and from my bedroom and my beds
in the background people are like do you
have a twin bed like it looks so
it looks so small like it actually it is
a queen but in like videos and stuff and
pictures it looks it looks like a full
it looks like a mr seabed honestly and i
actually had a dream
times with furniture delivery are so
long please just place an order like
please
it's so cool
like it's so complicated because we love
i first of all i love this bed frame so
i want to keep it and we love this
mattress so we want to keep it so we
need to wait until we have somewhere to
put this queen bed
before we get it put it in the living
room like i mean it's it really it's not
that big of a deal but i actually last
night i had a dream like in my sleep
that zach was taking up the whole bed it
was a dream though and then i got up and
i started screaming
and i was like
[Laughter]
but like that didn't happen in real life
i don't think oh my god that is
so [ __ ] funny you need a king bed
jacket i know dear toasters has taught
you nothing come on
i know i know and i just but when i do
get that queen bed it's gonna be king
king bet it's gonna be all the more
sweet you know it you're not ready for
it like you're going to die that you
used to sleep in a queen for so [ __ ]
long no and also like then bruce has
like it's just going to open up a whole
world
this quarter then there could be bruce
corner which is going to be so good yeah
so you need to have things to look
forward to in life and that is something
that i'm really looking forward to okay
um well thank you to everyone who wrote
into dear toasters and was vulnerable
with us and thank you for the update if
we've read you um some advice in the
last couple months please we'd love to
hear from you you just like use our
advice and then leave us high and try we
need to hear updates so email us updates
email us any quandaries you may have
deartoasters gmail.com that is our show
jackie i know you have important doctors
appointments today so i will just
quickly promote my song 100 available to
stream available to purchase on itunes
and my book is available in paperback
finally starting today available
anywhere you get books and the picture
inserts are still in the paperback book
i know a lot of people were worried
about that myself included i wasn't sure
until recently
so that's our show anything you want to
promote jacks follow jackie ashrae
follow jackie ashrae that's my instagram
also it's never too late to become a
redhead we're recording i haven't
started the book yet um but i will and
then we're gonna record this weekend
we're reading ghosts of gotham it's a
divergence from what we've read it's
like sci-fi but the redheads and they
were skeptical they were like why the
[ __ ] are we reading this they are loving
it so i'm so excited for that episode
and then we'll get a danish choice after
that and and she always comes out strong
so it's it's the perfect time to become
a redhead if you want to read if you
want to just like pick up even one it's
one book a month which i think is very
it's very reasonable it's a good
frequency we're not asking for too much
and it's an amazing amazing community so
definitely check us out
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found so spotify itunes stitcher public
radio i have radio cast box all the
places wherever you listen to podcast
find out some morning chose and leave a
five star view about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are hope you guys
have an amazing day we'll see you
tomorrow for
hump day
bye